YUFEI ZHAO: All right.
We are going to continue our
discussion of extremal graph
theory.
Last time, we
discussed what happens
when we exclude a triangle
or more generally a clique.
And we wish to find a graph that
maximizes the number of edges.
And at the end of the
lecture, I stated the theorem
of Erdos-Stone-Simonovitz,
which says, recall,
that if you have a fixed H and
I wish to understand the maximum
number of edges in an n
vertex graph that is H-free--
so remember this
definition, this
is the maximum number of edges
in an n vertex H-free graph.
So we are going to be
looking at this quantity
in the next few lectures.
So the Erdos-Stone-Simonovitz
theorem
tells us that, perhaps, quite
surprisingly, this quantity
is largely covered by the
chromatic number of H,
even though H itself
might be quite involved.
So if you knew the
chromatic number,
you already know a
lot of information
about the growth rate
of this function.
And in particular, as long
as it's just not bipartite,
so that the chromatic
numbers at least 3,
we already know the
first order asymptotics
from the
Erdos-Stone-Simonovitz theorem.
However, when H is bipartite
so that the chromatic number is
exactly 2, then the
theorem tells us
only that this quantity
is little o of n squared.
Which is some
useful information,
but it doesn't tell
us the whole story.
And in the next several
lecturers, I want to explore
what more can we say
about this quantity
here for bipartite graphs
H. And it turns out
that there is a lot
that we do not know,
that there are lots of
open problems in this area
having to do with trying
to pin down the growth
rate of this function.
And, in particular,
for bipartite graphs,
there's a bipartite
graph that places
somewhat special rule, namely
the complete bipartite graph.
So K st, being the
complete bipartite graph,
with s vertices on one side and
t vertices on the other side--
so this is a very
nice bipartite graph.
And just to understand, the
extremal number for this graph
is a famous open
problem in this area,
and it has the name of
Zarankiewicz problem, which
is to determine or estimate
the extremal numbers
for these complete
bipartite graphs.
So I'll tell you pretty much
all we know about this problem.
And there are some
interesting things.
But we do not know
all that much.
Now, every bipartite
graph is a subset.
It's a subgraph of such a
complete bipartite graph.
So every bipartite H it is
a soft graph of some K st.
And we know that if H is
a subgraph of this K st,
then the extremal number for
H if your graph is H-free,
then automatically it
has to be K s,t-free.
So there is this bound between
these two extremal numbers.
So in particular, if you have
some upper bound on K st,
then you have some upper
bound on bipartite graphs.
Although, for specific
by bipartite graphs H,
maybe we can do better
than using this bound.
And we'll see examples of that
later in the course as well.
So what can we say about the
extremal numbers of these K
s,t's?
So the most important theorem
in this area of this problem
is the result due
to Kovari-Sos-Turan.
So the Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem
tells us that for every fixed
integers s and t--
s at most t--
there exists some constant C,
such that the extremal number
is upper-bounded by something
which is on the order of n
to the 2 minus 1 over s.
So it gives you some
upper bound, showing you
that it's not only subquadratic,
but there is a gap from 2
in the exponent.
Now, in combinatorics,
as is with many fields
of mathematics, it can
be somewhat intimidating
to newcomers when you
see a lot of names.
So every theorems
seems to be named
after a string of
mathematicians, some of whom
you may have heard
of, some you may not.
And I agree, it may be difficult
to remember who is who and what
is what, but I think this
theorem has a very nice way
to remember, which is that
it's a theorem about K st,
and this is the K s,t theorem.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So this is the K s,t theorem.
I want to begin by showing
you how to prove the K s,t The
proof is via a nice and not
too difficult double-counting
argument.
And I show you
some applications.
Let's prove this
theorem, and it's
by double-counting argument.
What are we going to count?
Well, let's start with the
object that we're working with.
So there's going to be a graph
G that has n vertices, m edges,
and K s,t-free.
And let's count the number of
stars, K s,1 in this graph G.
So we're counting
configurations like that.
I'll do an upper bound
and a lower bound.
So let's start with
the upper bound.
On one hand, every subset
of s vertices in the graph G
has at most t minus
1 common neighbors.
Because if they had t common
neighbors, then you get a K st.
So that's one down.
On the other hand,
let's see what
happens to the number
of common neighbors
if you knew that this
graph has a lot of edges.
So the number of stars--
well, I can calculate
this quantity explicitly
by running over all the
vertices of G. For each vertex,
look at its neighborhood
and choose s vertices
from its neighborhood.
So for each v I need to
find a subset of s vertices
from its neighborhood.
By convexity, I can
lower bound the sum
by the average, in
some sense, because--
let me first write
down the expression.
So I can do a convexity argument
that gives me this lower bound.
Here, I'm abusing
notation somewhat
and writing binomial
coefficients
with a real entry on top,
where I mean the expression
as you would expect, treating
this guy as a polynomial in x.
And the key fact
we're using here
is that this function
here is convex
for x at least and minus 1.
So, In particular, if you
think about this function here,
you have a lot of 0's, and then
it becomes convex afterwards.
So you can even think of
extending this function as 0
to the left of n minus 1.
So this is a convex function,
and you can apply convexity
to deduce this inequality.
But you know the
sum of the degrees.
That's just essentially twice--
I mean, that is the twice
the number of edges.
So we have this
expression right here.
So you have an upper bound on
the number of s stars coming
from K s,t-freeness and lower
bound on the number of s stars
coming from just having lots of
edges and applying convexity.
Putting these two
things together,
we find that there's
this inequality here.
Here, we are thinking
of s and t as fixed,
and we are trying
to understand how
m and n depend on each
other as they get large.
So it will be helpful to use
the asymptotics that n choose
s grows like n to the s divided
by s factorial for a fixed s.
So looking at that expression
and applying this asymptotics
to both sides, we have
this inequality here,
So I've eliminated s
factorial from both sides.
So now rearrange,
clean things up.
We find the following
upper bound--
m the number of edges in G.
And that's the expression.
So for fixed s and t it grows
like n to the 2 minus 1 over s.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where does the
right side of the inequality
come from?
Are you counting that from the
different cycles [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: So the
question is where
the right side of
inequality-- which inequality?
This one here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
YUFEI ZHAO: Right.
So here we are counting
the number of K s1's.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
YUFEI ZHAO: So here I am
upper and lower-bounding
the number of K s1's using
what we derived earlier.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you actually
care that s is less than
or equal t in the argument?
YUFEI ZHAO: The
question is, do we
care that s is less than or
equal to t in the argument?
The argument doesn't care.
But, of course, if you want the
better asymptotics for fixed s
and t as n gets large, you
should take s to be less than
or equal to t.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What happens
when t equals 1?
YUFEI ZHAO: What happens
when t equals to 1.
Well, that's a great question.
I'll leave you to
think about it.
If you know that your graph
has maximum degree n most t,
what can you tell me about the
number of edges in the graph?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Any more questions?
We'll come back to this theorem.
In fact, this will occupy us for
at least a couple of lectures.
Basically, is this
theorem tight?
And it is conjectured
to be, although that
is a major open problem
extremal graph theory.
We only know a small
number of values.
Well, for most
values of s and t,
in particular when s and
t are both equal to 4,
we do not know if
this bound is tight.
But there are some values
of s and t for which
we do know that it is tight.
For example, 2 and
2, 3 and 3, 4 and 7,
s and if t is
really, really large.
And I will show you
some constructions later
on, creating graphs G that are
K s,t-free for those parameters
that matches this K st bound
up to a constant factor.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For a fixed s,
what's the bound on t--
if there a bound on t for
t with equality cases?
YUFEI ZHAO: Right.
So the question is,
for a fixed value of s,
is there some bound on t for
which we get equality cases?
There is a conjecture
that this bound is sharp
up to a constant factor
for every s and t.
But we only know how to
prove that conjecture--
and I will tell you much
more about it later on--
when t is much
larger compared to s.
So there is a lot of unexplored
territory on this problem.
Any more questions?
Before diving into the
Kovari-Sos-Turan further,
I just want to show you
some neat applications.
And I want to begin with
a geometric application.
There is a classic
problem asked by Erdos,
back in the '40s, called
the unit distance problem.
Which asks, what is the maximum
number of unit distances
formed by n points in the plane.
Let me give you some examples.
If you have three
points, you put them
in equilateral triangle, and
all three distances are unit.
Great.
If you have four points, you
cannot place them so that all
six distances are units if
you're staying in the plane.
So the best thing you can
do is something like this--
so I'm drawing all the edges
that are unit distances.
If you have one more
point, it turns out
that's the best thing you
can do with five points.
With six points there are
some more possibilities.
Let me draw for you
some possibilities.
You can extend the
previous configuration
by adding more triangles.
And there are many
different ways
that you can attach
an extra triangle.
There's actually one more
way to do it with six points.
Namely, I can put them like
a projection of a prism.
So all of these
configurations have
the maximum number
of unit distances
obtained if you draw six points.
If you draw seven
points, it turns out
this is the best way to do it.
So you can go on for a while.
And people have.
So you can try to tabulate
for every n what's
the maximum number
of unit distances
you can generate having
n points in the plane.
And the question is, what
is the answer for n points?
And it turns out,
for this problem,
and for many problems
like it in combinatorics,
you can have a lot of fun with
playing with small examples,
but they are often misleading.
It doesn't really tell you what
the overall structure should
be like.
And it turns out this
is the major opium
problem for which we do not
understand what the structure
is like for large values of n.
So think n large.
What are some possible ways to
generate many unit distances?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Drawing triangles?
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
So one way is to draw
lots of triangles.
So extend this figure forward.
So let's do that.
Well, actually, let me give
you something even simpler
to begin with.
I can just put the n points
on a line, equal spaced, OK,
I get n minus 1 distances--
n minus 1 unit distances.
If I put them like that, how
many unit distances do I get?
AUDIENCE: 2 times n minus 1.
YUFEI ZHAO: Good.
2 times n minus 1.
So each new point gives you
two extra new distances.
And you can try to think
about how to do better.
Well, if you follow that
sequence of examples,
maybe you're limited
to such ideas.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are we allowed to
put points in the same place?
YUFEI ZHAO: You are not
allowed to put points
in the same place.
That's a great question.
But you're not allowed to
put points on the same place.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is for
something to keep
doubling the number of
points, the degrees get big?
YUFEI ZHAO: So I didn't
quite understand--
so you say if you put--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] something.
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like keep translating
in different directions.
YUFEI ZHAO: So you want
to take this example
and keep translating
in some direction
I think you'll run out
of room pretty quickly.
AUDIENCE: No, I mean just copy
it and put it over [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFEI ZHAO: I see.
You want to take
this configuration
and translate it in
some unit direction.
Well, then you double
the number of points,
but you don't actually increase
the number of units distances
all that much.
AUDIENCE: Don't we get each
point having one extra unit
distance added?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the suggestion
is we take some configuration,
let's say this graph G,
and I form two copies of G
by translating G in some unit
directions-- some generic unit
direction.
OK, great.
So what happens to the
number of vertices?
So n goes to 2m and
the number of edges
goes from m to 2m plus n.
Is that right?
OK, great.
So if you do that,
what do you get?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
YUFEI ZHAO: n log.
OK.
That's much better than before.
OK, good.
Good.
Very nice.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That
picture [INAUDIBLE]..
Let's start with the
construction for n over 3
and then replace each point
with a triangles-- equilateral
triangle.
YUFEI ZHAO: Right.
So the suggestion is to
start with some graph
G and then replacing--
so let's, as an example,
look at that one--
each vertex here by an
equilateral triangle.
But I want to maintain
the same unit distance.
So the-- uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: So you just
choose [INAUDIBLE]..
Or you choose [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Is this similar
to taking this graph G
and then translating it in
two different directions that
form an equilateral triangle?
I think it's-- yeah.
So it's a very similar idea.
And maybe you do a little bit
better in terms of constant.
All great suggestions.
Actually, this is really nice.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
two times [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFEI ZHAO: Two times--
you want to make a
constant correction?
OK, let me just do that.
[LAUGHTER]
Any more suggestions?
OK.
Yeah, all of this
is really nice.
So let me tell you what is the
best construction that people
are aware of, and this is A
construction due to Erdos.
And the idea is to think big,
not build from small examples.
So what Erdos did is to
consider a square grid of root n
by root n.
When I see something that's
root n that's non-integer,
I just think round down
to the nearest integer.
I have a square grid.
Now, if you take these
distances as unit distances,
well, you get something
which is linear in m.
So you don't gain that much.
But you can take any specific
distance as your unit distance.
So what we can do
is take a distance
that is represented
many times in this grid.
So let's take the unit distance
to be a distance root r where
r is some integer that can be
represented as a sum of two
squares in many different ways.
So, for example, if we--
so we can take some r so
that it has many appearances.
And if you know some
elementary number theory,
then you might
know that the best
way to do this is to take
r to be a product of primes
that are 1 mod 4.
In any case, you
can do this and you
can use some analytic
number theory
to calculate if you choose
the best possible value of r,
how many distances do you get.
So that calculation was
done, and it turns out
you get n raised to the power
of 1 plus some constant C
over log log n unit distances.
So this is better
than the constructions
we've seen before.
So what can we say
about this problem?
So this is a construction.
Well, then you want to
understand some upper bounds.
What can we say about the
upper bounds to this problems?
And let me show you a fairly
easy upper bound, which
can be deduced very quickly from
the Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem,
that every set of n
points in the plane
has at most on the order off
n to the 3/2 unit distances.
So not quite this bound,
but it's some bound.
So the trivial upper
bound is n choose 2.
So it's much better than
the trivial upper bound.
So here's the proof.
So let's consider the
unit distance graph, which
is basically the graphs
I've been drawing,
where you have the
vertices, the points,
and I join an edge
between two vertices if
and only if their
distance is exactly 1.
I claim this graph is K 2,3 free
Why is that?
Because if you have
two points, what
are their common neighbors?
Their common chambers
must all be at distance 1
from each of the two points.
So their common
neighbors must land
in the intersections of the unit
circles centered at these two
points, and they meet
at most two points.
So it's K 2,3 free.
Therefore, the
Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem
tells us that the number
of edges in this G
is upper bounded
by n to the 3/2.
And that's it.
That gives you some upper bound.
Any questions?
So it's an application
of Kovari-Sos-Turan,
where we design the graph
that has to be K 2,3, free
and the extremal number
tells us some information
about this graph.
What is the best
bound that we know?
So it turns out we do know
how to do a little bit better,
but not anywhere close to what
we believe to be the truth.
So the current best bound is
on the order of n to the 4/3.
And we'll actually see
a proof of this later
in the course, once
we've developed
something called the
crossing numbers inequality.
It's also a very
short, very neat proof.
I want to tell you about
another problem which
looks superficially
similar and also a really
interesting geometric problem.
And this is the Erdos
distinct distances problem,
which asks for the maximum
number of distinct distances
among n points in the plane.
The minimum-- thank you.
The minimum number of
distinct distances.
So maximum would be very easy.
Again, you have
lots of examples.
In fact, you can look at
basically all the examples
that we've given earlier
I mean, these two problems
are very much related
to each other.
If you want lots
of repeat distances
or if you want very
few distinct distances,
whether they seem like
they are very much related.
And, of course, you
can also write down
the inequality that
relates the two of them,
because the number
of distinct distances
is at least n choose 2 divided
by the maximum number of unit
distances--
in other words, the
number of distances that
can be repeated in any
single configuration.
So each of the examples
that I just erased--
so, for example, if you
put points on the line,
you have n minus 1
distinct distances.
And we already saw
the square grid,
so that might be a good
candidate to look at as well.
And there it takes
some more number theory
to figure out how many
distinct distances there are,
and this roughly
corresponds to the number
of integers that can be written
as the sum of two squares.
So this has been
calculated, and the result
is n divided by
square root of log n.
So that's the order.
And Erdos conjectured
that this example
should be more or less
the best you can do.
So these problems
look very similar.
But, actually, this
problem here was
solved in a spectacular
fashion about a decade ago
by an important paper
of Guth and Katz.
So Larry Guth is
in our department.
And they showed that every
set of n points in the plane
generates at least
on the order of n
over log n distinct distances.
So not quite what Erdos
conjectured, but nearly there.
And, in fact, all the previous
results were much worse.
So they were off
in the exponent.
But this one more or
less got to the truth.
So this is a very
sophisticated result
that used lots of
amazing techniques,
ranging from the polynomial
method in combinatorics
to some algebraic geometry.
And that's-- I just wanted to
mention it for cultural value.
OK.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For the
unit distance problem,
what is believed
to be the bound?
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah.
So for the unit
distance problem,
and actually for the
distinct distances problem,
the question is, what was
is believed to be the bound?
And it's the square grid.
So maybe you can
do slightly better,
but it is conjecture that
you cannot do much better,
let's say, by more than a
constant factor compared
to the square grid.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is
Katz's first name?
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What is
Katz's first name?
YUFEI ZHAO: So
this is Nets Katz.
He's at CalTech.
I want to take a
short break now.
And when we come back,
I want to show you
some ways to generate lower
bounds to the extremal number.
In the Kovari-Sos-Turon theorem,
we understood some upper bounds
for the extremal number.
So I want to turn our
attention now to lower bounds.
Which means constructing,
in some sense,
graphs that have lots of
edges, at the same time being K
s,t-free.
There are many classes
of construction,
so there are several
techniques for doing this.
And I want to introduce you
to some of these techniques.
And the first one comes from
the probabilistic method,
where we use a randomized
construction by picking
a graph at random, modifying
it a little bit in a way that's
to our desire.
This method is very powerful.
It is very general.
It is applicable in
a lot of situations.
But, unfortunately, for the
problem of getting tight bound,
it really allows you
to get tight bounds.
So it is very robust, but
somehow it's often not sharp.
And another class of
constructions that
are algebraic--
all the sharp examples come
from algebraic constructions.
And there, we're able
to use some nice ideas
from algebra or from
algebraic geometry
to get tight constructions.
And you can wonder,
is there some way
to combine the best
of both worlds?
And it turns out--
this was an important
reason development
that was found just
several years ago--
where one can combine
ideas from the two
and obtain a randomized
algebraic construction.
And that leads to a new
source of constructions
for large H-free
graphs with many edges.
So the plan is to show you
how these constructions work.
First, let's begin with
randomized constructions.
As I mentioned, this
construction is very general,
it's very robust, and we can
use it to obtain H-free graphs
for every graph H. Of course,
when H is not bipartite,
then we saw from the Turon
graph that that's pretty much
the right thing to do.
So you should think of bipartite
graphs H. So fix a graph
H with at least two edges.
Otherwise, the
problem is trivial.
The claim is that there is some
constant C such that for every
n-- you should think of
and this being large--
there exists an H-free
graph on n vertices
and having lots of edges.
And we will show
that you can obtain
the following number of edges.
So 2 minus number of
vertices of H minus 2
divided by the number
of edges of H minus 1.
Don't worry about this
expression in the exponent,
it will come out of the proof.
In other words,
the extremal number
is at least this quantity here.
How good is this now?
So it's some scary looking
expression in the exponent.
So let me just give you some
special cases for comparison
to the Kovari-Sos-Turon theorem.
For K s,t's, the bound, this
construction gives you a lower
bound which is of the form m
to the 2 minus s plus t minus 2
divided by s,t minus 1.
So I used this symbol,
this bigger tilde
to denote dropping
constant factors.
In particular, setting
s and t to be the same,
we find that the K s,s extremal
number is lower-bounded by this
quantity here.
So how does that compare
to Kovari-Sos-Turon?
In Kovari-Sos-Turon we saw that
K s,s is at most 2 to the n
to the 2 minus 1 over s.
So there's a bit of a gap, and
in particular even for 2 and 2.
These results tell
you a lower bound
on the order of n to the
4/3 and the upper bound
on the order of 3/2.
So I'm just doing
this explicitly
to show you that even in
sometimes the simplest case
there is a gap between
these two bounds.
Later on, we'll
see a construction
that shows that the
right-hand side is tight.
So this is the truth.
Randomized construction
gives you something,
but it doesn't
give you the truth.
On the other hand,
I want you to notice
that if t gets very
large as a function of s,
this exponent here approaches
1 over s as t goes to infinity.
So for very large values of
t, at least in the exponent,
it's not that far off.
Although, you
never get the right
exponent for any
specific essential.
So this is some limitation
of the randomized method,
but it's variable robust.
And, in fact, you
can use this result
to bootstrap it to a slightly
better one for some graphs H.
So, for example,
one might do better
by replacing this
H by a subgraph.
Because if you have
a subgraph, H prime,
and you construct your
G to be H prime-free,
then it is automatically H-free.
But maybe this theorem actually
gives you a better construction
when restricted to H prime.
And what can you do better?
Well, you can do better
if h prime is such
that whatever the quantity
that comes up in the exponent--
so let me write it like this--
is superior to the
exponent you would
obtain by just looking at H.
So let me give the name
to this notion here.
So let me call it the
2-density of the graph
to be whatever
quantity here that
would be the
maximum if you allow
to pass down to subgraphs.
So the 2-density of a graph H--
so denoted in literature
often as m sub 2--
to be the maximum where you are
allowed to look at subgraphs,
let's say, on at
least three vertices
to avoid degeneracies
of this ratio that
comes up in the expressions.
So then the theorem--
that construction
there-- implies
that the extremal number is at
least not just the expression
I've written, but
maybe sometimes you
can do slightly better
by passing to a subgraph.
So let me give you
a concrete example.
Suppose my H is this graph here.
So you can run the
calculation and find
what these numbers are.
So the number of vertices,
edges, and this ratio
here to be-- so 5
vertices, 8 edges, and 7/3.
And the idea here is
that it's more helpful.
So I want to create
something which is H-free,
but dense things
are easier to avoid.
So if I have something which
has a fairly dense core,
that's easier to avoid.
So maybe it's better to, instead
of looking at the whole H,
look at this K 4.
So if you can avoid K 4,
of course, you avoid H,
and maybe it's easier
to just avoid K 4
and not worry about some
of the extra decorations.
So if you look at this H prime
and go through the parameters,
you find that it is like that.
And it is somewhat
denser in this sense,
compared to looking
at the whole graph H.
So you can improve on this
theorem for some graphs H
where you can pass
to a denser core.
Any questions so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is this
method called the 2-density?
YUFEI ZHAO: The questions
is, why is this measure
called a 2-density?
So that's a name
given in literature.
It partly has to do
with these extra ratios.
So there are other notions of
densities that actually we'll
see later on.
So this term we'll
only see today.
So it's more of an ad hoc term
for the purpose of this course.
Later on, we'll see
notions of density
that are more relevant
for our discussions.
Any more questions?
So let me show you how
to prove this theorem.
The proof is very intuitive.
The idea is you take something
at random and then you fix it.
That's it.
Let's consider a random graph.
The Erdos-Rényi random graph--
so whenever I say random graph,
I almost always refer
to this one here.
And the Erdos-Rényi random graph
is obtained by considering n
vertices and each possible
edge appearing independently
and uniformly with
probability p.
And we're going to
decide this p later on.
So let me not tell
you what p is for now.
I'm interested in avoiding
H. So this random graph may
have some copies
of H. Let me count
the number of copies of H.
We can compute the expected
number of copies of H
by linearity of expectations.
For every possible
placement, look
at what's the probability that
that placement generates an H.
Namely, look at all
different possibilities
for choosing the possible
vertices of H. I need
to divide it by a
factor that accounts
for the number of
automorphisms of H.
But just a constant factor--
don't worry about it.
And for each of these
possible placements,
H appears with
probability exactly p
to the number of
edges of H, just
by linearity of expectations.
And I can upper-bound
this quantity
very crudely by e to the
number of edges of H times
n, which is the number
of vertices of G raised
to the number of vertices of H.
On the other hand, I also want a
graph G that has lots of edges,
because that's what
we're trying to do.
We're trying to generate
a graph with lots
of edges that's H-free.
So the number of edges of G,
that's also easy to compute.
It's a binomial distribution,
and it has expectation p times
n choose 2.
And, basically, I
want this quantity
to be much larger
than that quantity.
So I choose an appropriate p.
Namely, by comparing
these two quantities,
we can choose p to
be, let's say 1/2--
the 1/2 is not important--
times n to 2 the v of H minus
2 divided by e of H minus 1.
So the exponent comes out
of comparing these two
expressions.
So you see a 1 and a 2.
Once you have this p,
see that the number which
is the difference-- so take
the number of edges of G
minus the number
of copies of each.
I know the expectation of both.
I can look at their difference
with this value of p.
We find that it is at least
1/2 of the number of edges.
So on expectation, you
don't lose too much.
So p is chosen so that
this inequality is true.
So you set what p is.
We find that this quantity here
is at least some constant times
n to the 2 minus v of H minus
2 divided by e the H minus 1.
We're still working
with a random graph,
and we know that this quantity
here is on expectation at least
that number-- so not too small.
Therefore, there exists some
instance in this randomness,
some G such that the
quantity above for
the specific random instance
is at least its expectation.
So this gives us a graph G which
on one hand has lots of edges,
but also has very
few copies of H
relative to the number of edges.
So we can now get rid
of all the copies of H
by removing one edge
from each copy of H
in G to remove all
copies of H. And now, we
obtain an H-free graph.
How many edges are
there in this graph?
Well, we removed at most
one edge for each copy of H.
So the number of edges is
at least this quantity here,
which is what we wrote just now.
And that's it.
So now we've obtained
our graph on n vertices
with lots of edges with the
claimed bound that's H-free.
So this is the
probabilistic method.
You start with something random.
You try to fix it.
And this method
sometimes has the name
of the alteration method.
And this is a very
important idea
and one of the key ideas in
the probabilistic method, which
I encourage you to go
and learn more about.
We'll also see this
method later on when
we discuss the randomized
algebraic construction.
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify, none
of the copies of H [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFEI ZHAO: So the
questions is-- yes--
what do I mean by the
number of copies of H?
I mean every instance
of H you see.
So there could be intersectings.
I'm not asking for
destroying copies.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
YUFEI ZHAO: So a complete
graph on n vertices
has n choose 3 triangles.
Any more questions?
OK.
So now we've seen that
the probabilistic method
gives you know some bound.
And it's not too hard to
apply, but it doesn't give you
the right bound.
It doesn't give you the truth.
So now, I want to show
you a different type
of constructions, namely
algebraic constructions that
do allow you to get
the truth, but they
work in only a small
number of cases.
And so it's more
magical, but they work
better when the magic happens.
So let's discuss
algebraic constructions.
In particular, I
want to show you
how to obtain the type bound on
the extremal number for K 2,2,
namely a fourth cycle.
So this is a result
due to Erdos-Rényi-Sos,
and it tells us that the
extremal number for K 2,2 is
at least 1/2 basically up to
asymptotics times n to the 3/2.
Actually, if you look at
the constant that came out
of the proof of the
Kovari-Sos-Turon theorem,
It is also 1/2.
So as a corollary, we see
that the extremal number
is like that.
So this is one of
extremely few cases
where we know the
extremal number so well.
So if you go back to the
proof of Kovari-Sos-Turon,
you see that the constant
actually there is 1/2.
So I want to construct for you a
graph that has no fourth cycles
and has lots of edges.
So that's the name of the game.
And I'll describe this
graph for you explicitly.
So this graph has a name.
It's called a polarity graph.
Let's suppose that n
is a number such that 1
bigger than this number
is a square of a prime.
So our construction will
use some finite fields.
I'll explain a bit.
If n is not of
this form, then you
can change n to a number of
very close to of this form,
and everything will be OK.
The graph will be
constructed as follows--
the vertex set will
be the plane over Fp.
Let's remove the origin.
So it has n points exactly.
And the edges are such that
I put an edge between x,y
and a,b, if and only if the
equation ax plus by equals to 1
holds.
And this equation is
meant to be read in Fp.
So that's the graph.
That's an explicit
description of this graph.
So I need to show
you two things--
one, that has lots of edges,
the claimed number of edges.
And two, it has
no fourth cycles.
So let's start with not
having fourth cycles.
So y is a K 2,2-free
So what would the K 2,2, be?
So let's consider two points.
And I want to understand the
number of common neighbors
of these two points.
Well, look at the
description for the edges.
What are the neighbors?
The neighbors
correspond to solutions
to this system of equations.
And the basic claim is that
there is at most one solution--
x,y.
So it's basic fact
linear algebra.
You have to be slowly careful
in case a,b is a multiple
of a prime b prime.
But, actually, in that case,
you have no solutions anyway.
The second claim then is that
this graph has lots of edges.
Well, actually, that's not
too hard to show either.
So I claim that every
vertex has degree--
so how many edges come
out of every vertex?
I give you a common b,
so how many x comma y
satisfy that equation up there?
Basically, for-- so 1 of
x and a and b is non-zero.
So let's say a is non-zero.
Therefore, whatever
value of y you set,
I can find a unique x
that solves the equation.
I have to be slightly careful,
because I don't allow loops
in my graph.
So I might lose one
edge because of that.
In any case, every vertex has
to agree exactly P or P minus 1.
Just solve that
equation in x and y.
So the P minus 1
comes from no loops.
Therefore, the number of edges
is equal to the claimed bound.
So this finishes
the proof in case
when n has that special
number theoretic form.
But we can extend to all
values of n like this--
if n doesn't have
that form, then I
can take a prime P.
It may not necessarily
be exactly satisfying
that inequality,
but I can always take a
prime pretty close to it.
So I can always
take a prime which
is up to a negligible
multiplicative
error what I want.
And then we use--
and such that P squared
minus 1 is at most n.
And use the above construction
and add isolated vertices
to finish the job to
get exactly n vertices.
And the reason that
I can always take
a prime very close to
it is because there's
a theorem in number theory
that tells us that for n
large enough, I can
always find the prime
which is slightly less
than n but no more
than a negligible
multiplicative factor of n.
The best result
of this form is--
I'm just telling you
something in number theory
for cultural reasons--
due to Baker-Harman-Pintz.
And so, this is the
question regarding how large
can gaps between primes be.
So you might know the
[Bertrand's postulate]] theorem
that tells you there is always
a prime between n and 2n.
So what about between
n and n plus root n.
Actually, we don't know that.
So the best result
of the form is
that there is always a prime--
so for n sufficiently
large there
exists a prime between n minus
n to the exponent 0.525 and n.
In any case, this number here,
whatever it is is little n,
and that's enough
for our purpose.
So it suffices to look at n of
a special number theoretic form
where you're allowed
to use primes.
So that's the
construction there.
Let me show you a interpretation
of that construction which
I think is may be
helpful to think about,
and that's that you can
view it as the incidence
graph between points and
lines in projective space--
in projective plane.
So I start with a
projective plane.
So I can view a bipartite
version of that construction.
It can be viewed as the
point-line incidence
graph of a projective
plane over a finite field.
And by this, I mean put as
one vertex set the points
of the projective plane and
on the other side the lines.
And I put in an edge between
a point and a line if and only
if the point lies on the line.
So you can do this more
explicitly in coordinates
if you view points and
lines as coordinates.
And so the equation for getting
a point to be on the line
is like that.
So now why is there
no fourth cycle?
A fourth cycle would
correspond to two points lying
on two different lines, which is
not possible in this geometry.
So that's the reason for
that construction up there.
So no two points in two lines.
Any questions about this
polarity constructions?
AUDIENCE: Why is it called
a polarity construction.
YUFEI ZHAO: The
question is, why is it
called a polarity construction?
So it relates points and
their polars, which are lines.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why does this not
have-- like, on your two P
squared vertices, looking at one
vertex for every [INAUDIBLE],,
one vertex for [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So the question has to do with
the number of vertices here.
It's true.
Here, I double the
number of vertices,
and so I don't get
that constant there.
But what that graph up there--
that's not a bipartite graph.
It is identifying the
points and the lines
and overlaying the
two parts into one.
But if you don't care
about the constants,
this graph here may
be conceptually easier
to think about.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] to
generalize the polarities bound
to K [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Great.
The question is, can you
generalize this polarity graph
to K 3,3 and higher?
So that's what we're
about to do next.
So for K 3,3, what can you do?
So the main observation
here is that two lines
intersecting at most one point.
But there are other
geometric facts of that form.
So we're going to use one of
them to get K 3,3-free graph.
And this construction
is due to Brown,
that the extremal
number for K 3,3
is also at least a factor
1/2 minus total 1 times--
so now, what's the exponent?
What is predicted
by Kovari-Sos-Turon
is 2 minus 1/3, and Brown
obtains the correct exponent.
It turns out this is
also the right constant,
this 1/2, although
it doesn't follow
from the Kovari-Sos-Turon
theorem I stated.
One needs to do a
little bit extra work.
But it turns out it is
true that this is also
the correct constant.
And that's actually pretty
much all the cases where
we know the correct constant.
And there are other cases where
we know the correct exponent,
but these things tend
to be hard to come by.
So let me show you how
to construct this graph.
So it's based on a similar
idea as the polarity graph.
It has some more technicalities.
So I'm not going to
do the full proof
and just give you the sketch.
As earlier, I'm
using the same trick.
We can assume that n
has a special form.
Here, let me assume the
n is a cube of a prime.
I'm going to put s edges.
So first, the
vertices of my graph
are going to be points in
the affine plane over Fp.
Previously, the edges
had to do with lines.
And now, let's use spheres.
So the edges of the form where
I join two vertices like this
if and only if they're--
well, it's not
really a distance,
but it's something that
looks like the equation
of a sphere, where u is some
fixed non-zero element of Fp.
You may have to be somewhat
careful in choosing this u,
but let me not worry
too much about it.
So you fixed some
so-called distance,
even though it's not a distance,
and I join the vertices
whenever they satisfy that
equation having that not
distance.
What's the intuition here?
The intuition is that
I want to avoid-- so
how do I know that this
graph has no K 3,3?
Well, first, let's think about
what happens in real space.
So intuition in the real space--
well, here, I have this
graph that, let's say,
the unit distance graph in r3.
So the neighborhood of each
point is a unit sphere.
And what I want to know is
that if you have three spheres,
three unit spheres, how many
common intersection points
can they have?
Two spheres
intersecting a circle.
And that circle cannot
lie on the third circle.
That you should think about.
So that circle intersects
the third circle
in at most two points.
So three unit spheres have
at most two common points.
And so the unit distance
graph in r3 is K 3,3-free.
That entire argument,
even though I expressed it
geometrically, it's
an algebraic argument.
You can write down
equations on intersections
between two spheres.
It's the intersection of the
sphere with its coaxial plane.
I have a couple of
these colossal planes.
They get me a coaxial line.
That line has to intersect the
sphere in almost two points.
You should actually
do this algebra
if you want to do the
proof, because there
are funny things that can
happen you find fields.
For example, maybe the
sphere contains a line.
But you choose your
parameters correctly,
and these things don't happen.
And that's the intuition.
And if you actually
work this out,
you'll find that this graph
here is indeed K 3,3-free.
So I'm skipping the details.
But you should do the algebra
if you want to have a proof.
On the other hand, it
also has lots of edges.
And that's basically the
same reason as before.
But I can count
the number of edges
by fixing some x, y, and z,
and look at how many abc's
satisfy that equation.
And that's, again, something
that needs to be checked,
but the point is
that this graph--
so every vertex has
either a P square--
so it has close to
P squared degree.
So lots of edges, and combining
with basically the same idea as
before, you get
the construction.
Any questions?
So where can we go from here?
To construct the K 2,2--
by the way, if you
construct K 2,2-free,
the same construction
works for K 2,3-free.
If it's K 2,2-free, then, it's
also K 2,3-free or K 2,4-free.
Here, likewise, this
is also K 3,4-free.
So now, what about
higher K s,t's?
And you might think, well, let's
take these geometric objects
and try to extend them further.
But that actually seems
kind of difficult.
We do not really
know how to do it.
We do not know how to
obtain a construction which
is of this form that
works for K 4,4.
In fact, there are
even some evidence
that that might be
even impossible.
As I mentioned, K 4,4
is a major open problem.
It is an open
problem to determine
the order of the
extremal number of K 4,4.
But in any case,
this construction,
this idea of using
algebraic constructions,
is very enlightening, that
we should look at ways to get
large K s,t-free graphs by
coming up with clever algebraic
constructions.
And next, time I will show you
a couple of very nice ideas
where you can get--
you can come up with a different
kind of algebraic construction
which has some superficial
similarities to what we've
seen today but that's really
of a different nature.
So, next time, we will
see the following theorem,
which is obtained in a
sequence of two papers,
union of authors,
Alon, Rényi and Sazbó,
that shows that if t
is much larger than s--
so minus 1 factorial plus 1--
then the extremal number for
K s,t is on the same order
as the upper bound determined
in Kovari-Sos-Turon theorem.
Just to be more explicit
about what these s and t are,
if you plug in
what's the smallest
t that this theorem gives
for various values of s,
find 2,2, and 3,3.
And the next one is 4, 7.
And then, it gets
worse from there.
So these constructions
are based on--
I mean, they are
algebraic constructions.
So we'll see next
time what happens.